we're bringing you some breaking news
out of Nottingham in the UK police there
are saying a 31 year old man has been
arrested after three people were found
dead in different locations in the city
center multiple roads are closed and
police and emergency services are at the
scene the tram Network says that it
suspended all services and the public is
being asked to avoid the area we'll
bring in Nadim Baba he's joining us from
London to tell us about what more we're
learning about this incident Nadim
well just in the last quarter of an hour
or so finally the police have issued
some detail uh suggesting what lay
behind the uh announcement a couple of
hours ago of a major incident in the
city center of Nottingham now they've
said that a 31 year old man has been
arrested on suspicion of murder that
followed a call to the police uh shortly
after four o'clock in the morning local
time uh to a road where the police found
two people dead that was ilston Road in
the city center then they were called to
another road where they say a van had
tried to run over three individuals
those three are now all being treated in
hospital and then the police went to
another location where they found one
person dead so a total of three people
were found dead in the early hours of
Tuesday in Nottingham City Center the
police have not given us any more
details about any motives for example
but that it seems is what was behind the
announcement by the local tram Network
that they had shut down all their
operations although other forms of
Transport were still running and those
pictures that we can still see the live
pictures from Nottingham City Center
showing a fairly calm atmosphere but
showing police including armed police
which is fairly unusual here in the UK
but people walking around as well fairly
uh unconcerned about their uh potential
safety just to repeat that this seems to
have happened in the very early hours of
Tuesday Morning in Nottingham City
Center it's the largest city in the East
Midlands here in England were waiting to
hear a bit more about exactly what lay
behind those uh three deaths okay Nadine
you'll keep us across the story thank
you so much for the time being nazimbaba
reporting from London